this week on quadriga germany votes high
stakes for europe
germans head for the polls this weekend
will they choose to stick with what they
know
or decide to give the opposition a
chance at the helm
will the political landscape in europe's
most populous country and largest
economy change
and what will the outcome mean for
europe
your host this week melinda crane
hello and welcome to quadriga what if
anything will change after this german
election
that's one of the questions that we want
to talk about today with three
correspondents who've been following the
election very closely and they are
ulrika winkelmann she's been reporting
and writing for the berlin-based
newspaper the tuts since 1999 and she's
now one of its chief editors for
domestic politics
and with lauren lucchini she's an
italian born freelance journalist based
here in berlin she's writing for el pais
in spain and for the italian publication
linkiesta
and i'm very pleased to welcome back to
the program alan posner he was born in
london and grew up in kuala lumpur and
west berlin he contributes to a variety
of media among them the debate magazine
the european and the german newspaper
divelt
let's start out by taking a look at what
the rest of europe thinks about this
election and what it's expecting and
laura lucini perhaps you can give us
some insights into what some of the
southern european countries are thinking
yeah of course in italy there's a
general recognition that what will
happen in berlin and sunday will have an
effect on on the wall europe of course
in italy uh the voters the the electors
had been
uh quite
angry mad to angela merkel because
uh because of the australia austerity
policies she imposed
during the crisis to all south european
countries
uh there had been like a moment of uh
really strong tension between the two
countries and the and that was uh uh
like last summer when the when the the
the crisis got really really strong
and it was impossible for italy to
borrow uh to finance
the debt on the on the financial markets
um
has that tension reduced now is is there
a sense that the worst might be over
yeah
that was i was gonna uh say that they
realized in a moment that they had a
friend in germany but it was in berlin
he was in frankfurt and i'm talking
about uh uh the the director of uh
european central bank mario draghi when
he announced this outright monetary
transaction that
like managed the announcement managed to
reduce the pressure of the spreads
between the german bonds and the italian
bonds and so also it had also a
political consequence that the
uh
italy started to felt that there was a
bright recognition about what the the
the central bank did
and may it may change uh something on an
european level they are asking for more
flexibility on this kind of policy
because just without 30 we people in
italy have the feeling that they are not
going to succeed they're not coming out
from this crisis they didn't like merkel
to say uh what is good for us it's going
to be good for you as well because they
don't think it matches they think italy
is another country
of course italy need to do reforms but
it's not 100 in the same country so you
say they're looking for greater
flexibility in just a moment we're going
to talk about whether in fact a new
government might deliver that but let me
ask alan posner first first of all the
english media what are they expecting
what are they saying about this election
i just got back from london actually i
was there on monday and tuesday talking
to people the bbc and
think tanks and and so on
and they too want more flexibility from
angela merkel and they're hoping for it
because david cameron you know he's he's
facing
uh a referendum on british on britain
staying in uh the european union are
going out in 2017 at the latest and he's
hoping that angela merkel will agree to
the treaty changes he needs to
give back some power to
uh to the nation states in this case of
course britain
and um the id she's been making
some noises like this and i think it's
interesting that the italians are hoping
for sort of a closer union and and
germany to
pay more if you will to to subsidize
their debt whereas the british are
hoping because she's made those kind of
noises that there's actually going to be
uh less integration she's going to agree
to a looser european union which was
across the board the idea that people
seem to have in london so in general a
bit of a cipher perhaps saying different
things to different audiences we'll come
back in just a minute to those
expectations and whether they will be
met but eureka winkelmann if we look at
this campaign in general actually the eu
european policy have played a very very
minor role i think in the in the debate
between the two candidates for
chancellor it took up all of about eight
minutes of an hour and a half how do you
explain that to an international
audience what's going on here in this uh
by most accounts rather boring election
campaign yes and everybody thinks that
europe is the most boring issue to talk
about
the germans
do not like to talk about the euro
crisis the financial crisis and they do
not like to talk about europe all
together because it makes them feel
uncomfortable they know that actually
half of europe
is mad with them because
obviously our wealth goes at the expense
of southern europe
but
everybody knows that the situation is
too complex to be pinned down in two or
three sentences and to be explained on
tv and especially the spd doesn't have
an interest to talk about europe because
sbd always has problems making clear why
they actually voted for all medical
plans at the same time saying well
actually but we still have some other
ideas which oh we can't explain right
now and
it doesn't
make people very comfortable to know
that the svd
pretends to know better
says they have some demands some ideas
which might ease in the fate of the
southern european countries at the same
time lifting their hands for every
medical
plan there's been the last years you
talked about the discomfort of german
voters one of the things in in talking
more about europe one of the things that
is a bit puzzling when you look from
outside is the extraordinarily strong
support that the chancellor still
retains some of the highest popularity
ratings ever for this chancellor at the
end of her second term in office
how do you explain
this
strong proclivity on the part of the
germans apparently to stick with what
they have yeah
well you can talk a lot about germans
being
conservative and being
frightened of everything new
but i think this special situation
is ruled by one sentence which has been
very famous the last 20 years it's the
economy stupid i mean
germany is doing well economically and
if the economy wasn't that fine of
course everybody would be more critical
of merkel at the same time she has
indeed got a personality
of which even
the critics of her
like for example my newspaper
do not really make sense how it works so
fine she has an appearance of
integrity she has an appearance of
honesty which really can hardly be
scratched only we call her teflon lady
because whatever you try to criticize of
her it somehow it just drops off
it's the impression we have as a foreign
journalist that nobody is criticizing
that like directly angela merkel on the
media because it's also really unpopular
i mean people
don't seem to like to to read that angle
american is doing bad things i mean i
remembered in the middle of the
the crisis uh when uh all the greeks
were made into angela merkel and all the
italians and uh spaniards as well and
then suddenly anderson come out with
with the special issue about how
everything is beautiful in germany and
with interviews to italian and greek
people saying that anger america was
good i mean we have the feeling that
sometimes the the press in germany has
been has been to to
to mellow with the anger america but on
the on the other hand of course alan
postner intellectuals have been anything
but mellow they've basically accused the
entire nation of being asleep at the
wheel
one interpretation that i saw this week
shed some light on that and i'm
wondering to what extent you agree
namely that underneath the sense that
germany is doing fine economically is a
very deep-seated insecurity about where
things might be going and that
chancellor mackel manages to calm that
insecurity and give people the sense
that they are in
sure hands
well that's definitely what she's based
her her campaign on basically the shore
hands you know trust me you know me
um that's the first secret of her
success the second secret is that she
never comes out with any explanation of
her policy she never declares i'm going
to do this because of that
um uh there's no big decision there's no
vision the vision thing as as george
bush senior said that's not her thing at
all so there's nothing you know to
criticize um she's never said anything
she's always she always presents things
as a complete
and um and this is why people get the
impression yes she's mooty she's mommy
she's gonna take care of things to kiss
things better and the fact that
in fact germany isn't in such a good
position that we have very serious
problems also economic problems up ahead
doesn't seem to gain any traction that
style that you just described of course
would be an ideal style for reacting to
crisis and there were plenty of crises
in her first two terms that she did need
to react to the question is looking
ahead if she were to win a third term
will she change that style and become a
real reformer i'd like to talk about
that but before we do let's take a
little poll here to find out what
everybody thinks about who will win this
election we've all been more or less
assuming she is going to get a third
term but i'd like to i'd like to know
which coalitions each of you thinks is
are most likely to come into being and
what that might mean for european
politics starting with aurica i would
find it a disaster but i'm afraid we'll
have a grand coalition of cdu and sbd
social democrats now in the opposition
with angela merkel's christian democrats
and what would you expect from a
coalition like that
nothing new
mecca will not change her style she's
actually used to the social democrats
she's then going to be in charge with
and the spd will try to put through some
social reforms of course
but it'll actually be due to the
economic position we'll then be in which
might be gloomier the coming two years
uh if they really make it
so mecca won't won't change okay our
leukemia what do you think we're in
stays in store i think it's the death of
politics but i would bet on a grand
coalition as well
i think on a european level a strong
presence of social democrats and it's
our hope
like south european
would allow
more flexibility on the european issue
and a stronger even if they're governing
with the current uh christians i think
so because angela marcus started uh to
recognize that he had to put an accent
on impulse on their growth and they
started with some announcement just
formal announcement about
making something to uh um to fight
the problem of unemployment youth
unemployment in europe i think this
would be one of the first
issue that a grand coalition would
address just after the election of of
course this this topic disappeared
during the electoral campaign because uh
angel american wouldn't have to say
wouldn't like to say that
germany will pay to to impulse
employment in other country when when in
germany there's no problem about that
but i think it will be one of the first
issues because put every everybody uh
agrees on it and would be like
opening a door to europe
so you see a bit of change on on eu
policy and yet you also say death of
politics that seems like a contradiction
of course because i see a grand
coalition a solution that a country
should take in some emergency moment
like in italy we have it but in italy we
have
emergencies
and
here in germany where
the situation is relatively better and
relatively good compared to the rest of
europe
i would have opted in
in a government in a political
government would with a majority in uh
capable to to change things to reform
the country to put it forward i don't
think i mean that the
the grand coalition is the debt of a
debate the political debate it kills the
interest in politics it's uh it sleeps
the the
people and and that's that's what i
don't like of a grand coalition
alan posner i'm going to ask you
for two takes on this because i did read
an article in which you told the public
how you plan to vote so i'd like to know
that and i'd like to know what you
actually think is going to happen on
sunday well i'm going to vote for angela
merkel with gritted teeth because i
don't think she's done a very good job
and i'm going to give my second vote to
the free democrats because i think that
germany needs a liberal voice junior
coalition
to remind ourselves who i think also
suck quite frankly
but
you know the devil you know
um so so that's what i'm going to do so
you would be voting to essentially keep
the same government in office uh
basically yes uh
through gritted teeth and also because i
think that it's by no means a foregone
conclusion that mackerel will win i
think it's perfectly possible that the
euro critical alternative for germany
rfd alternatively deutschland uh does
take a does get more votes than people
uh think they will
and they might take them away from macos
right wing coalition center right
coalition and that could lead to a
surprise upset and to a red green
majority
if only just
and that i think would be an even
greater disaster than macros so it's the
devil in the deep blue sea if you will
and i'm choosing
the devil and what do you think will
actually happen
i'm afraid we're going to have a grand
coalition in the end as as as
everyone thinks in germany now
and um and i'm afraid you will not get
what you want um i think the point about
the grand coalition why it might not be
such a terrible mistake is that we're
going to have to do some really really
hard thinking on europe and the euro
in the next two three years it's not
going to get better
and
we will need a grand consensus to do
whatever we have to do be it euro bonds
uh be it leaving uh the eurozone one of
the two now here's something that
confuses me a bit ellen posner because
the article that i mentioned
you said that you would vote for the
existing government because they would
be best positioned to essentially
terminate germany's membership in the
euro currency now that puzzles me among
other things because i think you just
told us the that the small party
alternative for germany alternative
deutschland as it's known which is very
much an anti-euro party you view as
problematic so
what's what's the story well the story
is that i think um the leader of the
alternative of deutschland look he's a
respected economist he's got something i
mean he's but the party is a party of
grumpy old men which are attracting
other grumpy old men and it's attracting
xenophobia and all the whole
everything that's wrong about german
politics gets sort of attracted to them
and
therefore i really hope they don't get
into parliament because they're they're
not a force for good i really hope
however that the present government
realizes somewhere down the line that
you can't go on with this uh present uh
european euro policy which has led to
the eurozone being a no growth in fact
negative growth zone which has led to
germany being universally hated in the
southern part of the euro zone and the
southern part of the eurozone being
universally hated in in germany it's a
terrible terrible situation which has to
be resolved somehow
but i'd like to alternatively like to
come back good let's stay briefly with
the question of the alternative did you
want to address that laura or a
different aspect yeah yeah okay so i
mean in italy we're looking to
alternative for deutschland with a lot
of interest because
as you may remember when we had the
election last february uh
a party which is
against the euro or got into the
parliament for the after after joining
the election for the first time it's a
completely different party the movement
of five stars but it's anti-politic
party but it also addresses the problem
of the euro in a really close way to
alternative for deutsche and they say we
want to go out from the euro or we would
like to have a referendum about that and
we we want to devaluate our currency and
it is exactly what alternative
deutschland
are
proposing uh the problem tourists do you
think alternative for deutschland would
be if they do get into parliament and by
the way my producers have just uh told
me that there is a new poll showing that
they most likely will get into
parliament they're now being assessed at
five percent that would just clear the
hurdle into parliament so um
how how risky would that be for germany
it's just a bad sign i mean they
wouldn't influence policy of course you
know but they do not influence policy i
don't think so i mean they will be as
small a small party as
anyways
but in a way it's a bad sign because uh
you know in italy
they got into parliament with the 25 27
that's a huge amount of votes
and if they start to have like a common
view with the german party and then
maybe in another country that start to
be a big problem it won't be a problem
in the next four years but it will it
will be a long-term problem rika
winkelmann alternative for deutschland
the finance minister wolfgang schweibler
has said
this party is poison for germany poison
clearly he does take it seriously as a
potential threat or perhaps just because
it's siphoning votes away from the cdu
how do you see it
well i wouldn't overestimate it even if
they get into parliament which i doubt
they won't have too much influence there
the influence they do have is in the
economic scene because there are a lot
of professors a lot of well-known and
well-reputed professors taking part some
of whom i've been talking to the last
years over social reforms and all sorts
of tax reforms for example and all these
are
intelligent people they are not stupid
and they are not in the old sense
conservative and to be left behind
and the kind of power they might have is
that they
put
and pin down
correct economic arguments of which the
cdu can't say you're just plain wrong
they will have to interact with them in
that way and this will enhance their
power even though there might be only
four or five people in parliament so
having an effect on public discourse
going forward so where are we going when
we go forward most likely in all of your
eyes with a grand coalition of the cdu
and the spd together to figure out what
that could mean for europe let's take a
closer look at where we stand now and
what the past four years have brought
the euro crisis has caused misery and
deeply indebted eu member states that
have been forced to reform
strict austerity measures championed by
germany were implemented to prevent the
collapse of the eurozone protest parties
in crisis-hit countries have since
profited from anger about demands made
by brussels
but in many countries germany is held
responsible for continued high
unemployment and slashed social benefits
despite that anger the majority of
germans still remain staunchly
pro-european and germany continues to be
viewed by other member states as a
success story as well as absolutely key
to the eu's future
although there were differences between
angela merkel and her challenger pierre
steinbrueck about the best way to heal
europe's woes their parties have largely
agreed on their country's reaction to
the crisis so even if germany's
political leadership changes after the
vote would anything actually change for
europe
winkelmann let's pick right up on that
question will anything actually change
the spd during the election campaign
when it did turn its attention to eu
policy called for a marshall plan for
the southern european countries that
would speak for laura lucchini's
notion that perhaps we'll see greater
flexibility perhaps some relaxation of
austerity policy and indeed some experts
believe we're already seeing that in the
past eight to ten months from angel
america's government what do you think
will that go
forward depending on who actually is in
office then who gets the finance
ministry and so on i would say yes
they'll try to
give more money to southern europe
basically if it's called marshall plan
then i would doubt that
there will be some
economic support i would say from from
sbd might be called a gabriel plan might
it
sigma gabriel of course being the
current head of the uh social democrats
who apparently might want to have a kind
of super economics ministry some people
are saying these pr people will be
listening closely now and thinking this
is a great idea make a garbage plan that
i think what they'll definitely try to
do is some sort of banking regulation
they have two points saying that the
banks have to sort of look after
themselves in the next crisis the
banking restructuring phong thing which
nobody really understands but it's
basically about
having the banks pay for themselves if
they're in crisis
and they also have
some point in saying we need to have
more taxes on capital we have to have
some kind of tobin tax working better
than the proposed plans at the moment so
i think there'll be an sbd package they
go into the coalition
and we'll see what happens then
winkelmann just mentioned banking union
this is one of the crucial issues as we
look ahead
and angela merkel has given us some very
conflicting signs on this particular
issue
as we discussed
she tends to say different things at
different times to different people
a couple of years ago she was saying we
need more europe we need more
integration we've got to get something
like a supra national government in
place in europe on banking union she's
been dragging her feet looking very much
like she does not want that kind of
integration what's the story there and
what do you expect going forward if in
fact we do wind up with the ground
coalition
well the story is that maca has
abandoned super europe and she's created
in its instead
an intergovernmental europe uh the
so-called currency and economic union
which or the fiscal compact these are
these are treaties between the
governments of the eurozone and she's
basically left the european parliament
the european commission and the council
behind her so she has
destroyed europe in a way and the
banking union is a is a similar thing
she does not want to give power over the
german banks who are notoriously under
capitalized to brussels to close down
for instance the german sparkassen which
are used by regional german politicians
for their own sort of um pet projects
and uh
so so she's proven with the with the
banking union that she doesn't mean a
thing she says about more europe she
actually wants an intergovernmental
europe where at the moment because
germany's strong we are setting the tone
but when we become weak as we will we
are going to have some real problems
sounds very much like a europe that
england would be quite content to remain
a part of
no actually um england would prefer a
reform of the eu as a whole england does
the interesting thing is that the one
country
which is for a united europe is in fact
at the moment great britain they would
prefer
powers to be
given to the member states but then to
pool the powers that they have and not
to go like maca does to split europe
into an intergovernmental eurozone and
the rest who don't interest her
yeah in in the lecturer campaign merkel
has sent a really sloppy message about
about europe she she's saying all the
time we want more europe but but but
that doesn't mean
uh we want to transfer more power to
brussels that's the key and i think of
course you said they don't want a
banking union because they have problem
with the spark but it's not it's not a
topic in the in their electoral campaign
and the spd couldn't bring up this topic
because espy has his own fault on on
managing the london bank in germany the
problem with london's bank
so germany is really acting really
egoistically in this moment because the
banking union would be like the first
step
for uh countries like spain or
or italy to um
hell their their bank system without
uh getting to like a
help program or
health packages like greece and that's a
that's a huge a huge issue
which that angela merkel doesn't address
really openly and sincerely
enrique vincent to what degree
is this a product of
campaign tactics would you expect that
once the election is finally over angela
mackel could take stronger steps
particularly on banking union than she
has in the last
10 to 12 months
well to me there is a very rational
reason for not supporting the banking
union as it's been designed so far
also the opposition says there might be
a problem trying to capitalize banks
directly with taxpayers money i mean i
see a problem in
having the banks directly capitalized
with my taxpayers money
and so this is one reason why the
opposition doesn't
is not too aggressive about this point
and i think the banking union so far as
it's been designed so far would work to
the uh
well not to the benefit of the taxpayers
but it might come to the catastrophic
outcome that
we taxpayers again have to capitalize
the banks in europe
without any democratic control and and i
i don't like that the main idea was that
the bank themselves would contribute to
create a fund to save other banks but
then of course that's the risk yes and
already uh some bankers said that they
could use the esm the first step to to
save banks and that that of course is a
crucial issue perhaps we need to step
back just for a moment to remind our
viewers who of course are scattered
throughout the the entire world alan
posner why this is such an important
issue at the moment things look pretty
calm in europe many people
seem to believe the worst of the crisis
might be over why this big focus on the
banking union as a test of where europe
and where the chancellor herself are
going
well because the
euro crisis basically was
a banking crisis it was a crisis of
confidence in
in european banks
and
this was the reason why
why they then clamped down on european
governments and their debts and so on so
resolving the banking issue we have lots
and lots of banks here who have too much
sovereign debt on their books bad
sovereign debt greek debt italian debt
spanish debt portuguese they had irish
debt and so on and to somehow resolve
this this this
problem and free up credit is very
important for for europe and the idea is
the question is do the nations get
through it themselves do they get to do
it with the help of the european
stability mechanism or do they do it via
banking union and
the real problem is indeed what
say do voters in the individual
countries have to do with this and that
the point is that it's always been
shifted away to some strange european
mechanisms no one knows anything about
it who knows actually who's
saying what in the european stability
mechanism which lends
millions or billions of euros to spanish
banks no one i mean this is something
that is done behind closed doors rika
winkelmann basically
it comes down to the question how stable
is europe at the moment to what degree
is the crisis simply latent and ready to
resurface at any moment or to what
degree
have european policymakers albeit with
muddling through small steps whatever
you want to call the very incremental
policy making that angela merkel herself
has engaged in managed to get the crisis
under control
it is not it is not under control i
think hardly anybody would say except
for schweibler our finance minister that
it is under control
and
everybody knows that
greece
portugal slovenia now are in a shaky
condition and nobody knows what's going
to happen in france and um
and
i'm just being too polite to mention
italy actually and so i would say
there's no control the question only is
if the policies of buying time which is
essentially what they are doing the last
five years
is
working in a sense that if you buy your
time out of this crisis that finally the
financial markets will come down in a
way that they're not threatening our
societies and our states as a whole
anymore
laro lucchini many people have argued on
that particular basis that while crisis
management the policy of small steps uh
that angela mackel is so often said to
to have pursued that this will not be
enough moving forward that we need
vision we need strategy do you think
that's right and if so do you believe
that a grand coalition under angela
merkel is capable of that no
i don't think so uh i don't think
i mean
i think all europe should everything
should put themselves
like the big question what do what do we
want from europe how how forward are we
are we open to to go to to build this
european uh union and uh how much other
otherwise if not we we will have to have
the the chance to leave the the the
currency um
i don't think
nobody in in italy is expecting huge
changes
um
of course europe need more more vision
or maybe more courages as well but i
don't
see it coming from this government that
this will be again a government of
acting on small steps
pretending to do something big when
they're just doing something really
really small
but of course
it's
it all depends also on how the situation
develops for example in italy because we
could go
to election uh really soon if the
government doesn't resist
uh this moment in which berlusconi is
about
the all political leaders berlusconi is
about to be kicked out from the senate
because of his problem with the justice
and that could cause a political crisis
and then after that we don't even know
what is going to be our future so we
we're we're not hoping too much in
germany saving us
alan posner interestingly enough one
british publication the economist came
out with an endorsement of angela mackel
as uh next chancellor for germany and
not only next chancellor for germany but
leader for europe those were their words
so far she has tended to lead if at all
very much from behind
would you expect her in a third term her
last term traditionally the time when
leaders begin to think about the history
books to come out from behind and take
true leadership
no
quite frankly the economist
based everything on the hope that she
would do that but what does this what is
this hope based on judging by past form
that's not the way angela merkel
operates she i mean you said it like
it's it's incremental
step by step uh trying to buy time the
problem is that time isn't on our side
it's not in europe's side and it's not
on germany's side because we have a
demographic problem we have a problem
with the structure of our industry which
is based much too much on cheap labor
and cheap euro by the way and um
so
time is not on our side but macker's
policy is buying time shoving problems
down the road in the hope that they will
somehow solve themselves now she's been
lucky with this um and whenever she's
actually tried to do a policy decision
like she changed our stance and she was
for atomic energy so that was her main
sort of sort of thing four years ago i
i'm going to be uh for atomic energy and
she did that what happened it blew up in
her face literally with fukushima so
she's not going to do that again that's
not her style she's she
and and and this is why i fear
um that we're going to get more of the
same who whoever leads germany clearly
eureka winkelmann until now germans have
been comfortable with the leading from
behind the small steps the crisis
management
approach to what degree would they and i
include you
want to see their chancellor come out
and really take leadership within the
country but also
open leadership in europe well it would
frighten me to be honest
because i don't think that she's
following the right direction and it's
not all germans being content with her
we've got one third of the population
obviously uh in a
worse state than 10 or 15 years ago we
have a kind of working poor
class of people who didn't exist
15 years ago and those people are not
content it's just that they are not
being asked and um
so so if she came out with leadership i
i would be afraid but
this should then be being really openly
neoliberal again as she used to be ten
years ago trying to to
throw around ideas which she wasn't
being elected for 10 years ago and so so
i wouldn't approve of that let me ask
you the question again divorced from
angela merkel herself
your country
is it ready to assume that kind of
leadership under any individual who
might be elected are germans ready to
get out in front as the certainly they
are the de facto giant in europe are
they ready to become that politically as
well
no no they like to be the economic giant
but they don't they don't not want to be
asked to be any other kind of giant
nobody here wants to
lauren leukini
that's really clear if you live in
germany but
i i really notice and hear that people
from outside expect germany to do
something more i mean
if they are in this stronger position
and if they impose uh adjustments to
other countries they should also take
more responsibility that's always the
refund you you listen when you travel to
other countries but then being in
germany you really realize that nobody
in germany would open for such a for
such a position in europe they really
don't want they are not interested in
that
alan posner is it a generational issue
is it
something that is of course a legacy of
the second world war that we will see
slowly dissipate when the current
political generation and i'm i'm talking
about the people between 50 and 60 do
begin to make way for younger
politicians here
no actually i think when people talk
about germans historical legacy and we
don't want to leave because we
uh because of the second world war the
first world war whatever that's just uh
that's just obfuscation that's not the
real reason um
you know we
the red green government went into
kosovo the red green government went to
afghanistan they had didn't they weren't
worried about about wars and so on um we
had a war on the balkans we have a
warren
in the hindu kush area so you know that
that was done when when joshua fisher
stood up very bravely and said that the
one lesson from world war ii is surely
that it was fight against fascism and
and he was quite right he got a lot of
beating from it um but what accounts for
the retrenchment since then well because
we feel very complacent about opposition
uh in the world we got through the
financial crisis okay we got through the
euro crisis fine so why on earth should
we change anything this is the the the
complacency of the of of germans in
which they then choose to say
to to to clothe in in as a moral issue
oh no because we did so many bad things
we're not going to do any good things
now i mean this is really really crazy
that's quite a fascinating notion the
idea that the moral stance that we often
hear germans take
no we're very shy of leadership we're
very shy of military involvement we
can't do that because of the sins of the
past is actually a cloak for
economic interest and
a simple desire for comfort there's more
than a grain of truth to that i would
say i would also say that the historic
narrative is not over and dead but it is
still there but at least for those
people i would say under the age of 50
it is more
that they want to build big cars they
want to drive big cars and then they
want to be left alone that's it
and i i do not approve of that but i
think still that the enormous power of
the german export industry which is a
machine building and car industry
lets us
sit down on our sofas and be complacent
and know that after all the economy
decides all of it anyway the economy
decides for us
isn't that to some degree
in fact true laura lucchini don't
politicians in nation states the world
over face ever less room for maneuver
ever less room to actually put their
stamp on things in other words to lead
we experienced that during the crisis
financial markets are deciding
instead of government and then and less
in the last instance people
but i don't think it's like
i think that can change if there is a
political will to do it i think people
in europe not just in germany not just
in italy they seem to sleep not to
react they don't understand maybe
did the
the dimension of what is happening
alan posner it sounds from what we've
said so far that
all the expectations that a third term
for angela merkel could be different
will in fact be confounded would you say
that's true i'd say that's absolutely
true yeah unfortunately
mind you events are going to shape her
third term not what she does what she
thinks or says
okay
i will say that sentence journalists are
trained actually never to see but in
this case it is perhaps pertinent um
time will tell
thank you very much to all of you for
being with us today and thanks to you
out there for tuning in stay with us for
the next four days we will be reporting
extensively on this election and what it
means thanks so much
you